a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever before as a new
subscriber joining today you'll pay just
one pound a week for unlimited online
and app access in your first year to
subscribe go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer
[Music]
john thanks so much for joining us on
spectator tv
now all the polling of the tory
leadership race seemed to show that liz
trust is way ahead of rishi sooner but
there does seem to be a lot of variation
uh on tuesday yougov had liz trust at 69
percent and which she seemed like a 31
meanwhile an italian firm had the pair
within five percent of each other
why is there so much discrepancy between
the polls
well we'd like to notice the answer that
questions
um
the two organizations did their polling
somewhat differently gov of course have
this quite substantial panel of people
who
are willing to answer their polls
almost in every one of the difficulties
with running such a panel is that you're
more likely to get people who are
interested in politics to participate in
them and those who are not one of the
things that
yougov amongst others have been trying
quite hard to correct in recent years um
because that can be a disadvantage when
it comes to general election if you've
got uh people who are more likely to
turn out and vote then you may
underestimate some of the differences in
turnout and that was certainly part of
the story
behind the problems that the polls had
back in
2015
but the upside of course is that it does
mean that you are much more likely to
have members of political parties in
your panel because they are by
definition just important so that's the
way you go doing things that's also the
way that opinion uh
things as well
technique who are the company that came
up with something different though first
of all they're relatively new to poland
in the uk
although they're well established in
italy which is their place
what they did to get their numbers from
what one can tell is i mean it was
basically part of a much bigger polling
operation in which they were sending out
emails at random to a database of uh
people whose email addresses they have
and also uh tell it bringing telephone
numbers outline them to a database of
telephone numbers stay hard so this is
less in the way of pre-selected people
um part of you know just part of the
general public but in the course of that
picked up
800 people who said they were
conservative members so it's a different
methodology
two companies have produced not
dissimilar results of their estimates
and both intentions of the public in
general over recent months but they're
clearly diverged in this case i think
all one can say is that you know
technique is a new company and maybe
they're right or maybe they're wrong
ugov's record of um leadership polls is
a pretty good one they were virtually
spot on in their estimates of the
proportion of labour party members that
we're going to vote for jeremy corbyn in
2015 and 2016 they were pretty much spot
on in the battle between cameron and
david davis in 2005 though they were a
little bit high
on boris johnson's score in the 2019
contest equally opinion who are the
other company who've done this in the
past and they're promising us
i know the poll next week they've got a
pretty good record indeed they've got
the boris johnson versus jeremy hunt
contest almost down to a single point so
it's a difficult thing to do we are
trying to get hold of a very specialist
section of the population they represent
less than one percent of the population
but one has to say
given their record in the past one
certainly cannot ignore
what comes out from the companies
that
have been doing this on a regular basis
and i guess the worrying thing for the
sunup camp is that
it's not just that the you know new
government showing this trust well ahead
um as indeed our conservative home with
their
survey of their of their members um but
also that apparently the story has been
the the movement has been our way from
which we've seen up towards uh towards
this trust and the truth is actually if
you look at the technical you looked at
some of the innards and again you could
see some of richard's sonat's problem so
there were hardly any issues in which
technique had
uh british sun out right ahead they were
one or two about civil rights lgbt
rights um a little bit on on the economy
but uh whereas there were a number of
issues like immigration others where
this trust was well ahead and actually
one could say well first of all let's
number even that ball had this class
ahead but secondly actually the overall
numbers of 48 to 43 for trust
seemed rather surprisingly narrow given
some of the other figures that were that
were there
and john we know we think of polls as
these things that measure voting intent
but with the polls coming out during the
race uh it surely has an influence on
how the race is panning out as well for
example the polls that we've just been
talking about they lend this out of
inevitability towards list trust's
victory and presumably that influences
whether it's other mps or other voters
into backing the winning course
well i'm talking about voters in general
um i mean the research that's been done
on this will tell you that for every
occasion that you can pick up a
so-called bandwagon effect of people
hiding in behind the party that's ahead
you can find another one where there's
an underdog event where people seem to
pile in the opposite direction right
we're not talking about
a polling of the general public we're
talking about
a small audience and where the outcome
is going to affect people's careers
inside the conservative party and i
suppose what is notable
is that even though liz trusts in the
end only just scraped onto the ballot um
if she does win this contest i think you
know she's going to be as low as anybody
who's been in terms of the
share of the uh supportive mps at the
final stage of the mps process
but despite that all of the
announcements we have got since the
senior mps including those
who either took part who had hoped to
take part in the leadership but have all
been coming out in favor of this trust
now not for me to impugn the motives of
those who've done this doubtless they
are telling us what they in their
judgment is indeed the best thing for
their party for the country but
shall we say if you were
wanting to
keep your open your chances of being in
this trusted new cabinet then such
statements perhaps may not be regarded
as unhelpful towards your uh your career
progression and to that extent at least
clearly um it can make a difference
to uh the way in which mps that but i
think it's also true that you know some
of rishi sunak's tactics have been
affected by the polling the
way which he tried quite clearly to try
to see if he could steamroller put this
truss on the back foot in the bbc debate
something which in the end for some
people came across as mother to
aggressive and mansplaining i know that
almost undoubtedly was saying i've got
what i've got to try to do here is to
persuade people that i am actually more
effective as prime minister more
competent which indeed
is one of the attributes one of the most
few attributes on which even in the
current volume
does score uh relatively well so again
tactics of the candidates can be mapped
it does of course
perhaps raise the question given that
this trust is apparently so far ahead as
to why she has carried on making so many
policy announcements
with therefore the risk that you make
one that leads you into trouble which
clearly happened to her this week with
the announcement about regional papers
once you're ahead just stick to your
message the narrative is working the
narrative that i am the empathetic
ordinary girl who grew up in paisley and
leeds i went to comprehensive school and
i'm opposing this posh boy from
winchester it's a narrative which we can
question
but it's a johnson style narrative in
terms of its effectiveness with the tory
membership together with of course
addressing the angst inside the
conservative party about the fact that
it's find itself presiding over high
levels of spending and high levels of
taxation is projected to do so uh into
the near future um it's just that he's
addressing that angst she has found a
picture way of selling herself
uh to certainly the right of her party
um and uh you know therefore in the end
therefore um you know why does she need
to make more policy announcements she
doesn't need any more policy
announcements she just needs to keep on
sticking to her current tune because
that current tune has won so far that
richard sunak has not been able to
significantly uh cancel fascinating
professor john curtis thank you so much
[Music]
you